bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i have robert
back with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
glad to be here palm thanks for having
me the last time we talked it was uh
pre covid um and we had a fantastic
conversation
really just breaking down uh kind of ray
dalio's thoughts around uh gold
stores value bitcoin uh etc sounds like
he has uh come around
uh quite a bit and uh maybe he's not a
full-blown bitcoiner yet
but uh but is definitely closer than he
was back then uh maybe give us just kind
of a
an overview in terms of what you've been
up to over the last year and a half or
two years
yeah last time we spoke almost exactly a
year ago
and it was i guess about two weeks
before the covet meltdown
um and that you know as we were just
touching on it's been like this singular
accelerating event for the bitcoin
thesis
the digital age in general um
so very strange times but also kind of
exciting to be in in the bitcoin space
um dalio it seems
has come around somewhat uh i think his
most
recent stance on bitcoin was that it's
one hell of an invention
so he's still not he still seems like
he's a bit lost
in the blockchain buzz world buzzword
jungle um and he still has some
concerns about you know volatility and
could bitcoin be disrupted by another
crypto asset et cetera et cetera so kind
of looking at it
as a consumer product i don't think he's
fully
grasped the nature of an internet
protocol
uh the nature of the the social layer
built on top of it
right that people holders specifically
all the rules in bitcoin are optimized
for holders so there's really
you can't there's not any design space
left to introduce a value proposition
that can break that network effect of
bitcoin i mean not a conceivable one i
mean anything can happen who knows but
um you know bitcoin is essentially as we
touched on in the last episodes has
perfected all the properties of money
and now we're talking about a one
trillion dollar asset
i mean this thing
yeah as sailor alluded to that when
these digital networks get above 100
billion which is you know 10x ago for
bitcoin
they tend to become indomitable right
they have such an entrenched
network effect um i you know the
i guess you could say the brand
recognition too is really important that
you can't even
mention a competitive crypto asset
without comparing it to bitcoin so
bitcoin has this kind of
self-reinforcing
narrative in the world and that's
ultimately what it is
right it's an idea the whole thing's an
idea and it it
runs countervailing to all of the
entrenched power interests
and central banks right their premise on
the opposite
world view that we should just be able
to expand the money supply
arbitrarily at will to fix all of our
problems
you know bitcoin flips the whole thing
on its head and says no
we should have a firmly fixed money
supply
that is a a sound power reservoir
for the the energy that we sacrifice the
time and energy we sacrifice to obtain
money
the money supply should reflect the
scarcity of the time and energy we
sacrifice to obtain it
and this idea i think is just
just tearing it's just breaking out
throughout the world
right you know again coven we have this
uh the sharpest liquidity collapse in
market history this is a
in the march 12th black thursday event
was a faster global equities drawdown
and flight to safety
than the 1929 collapse now the
so far the repercussions of that have
not been as
severe um but as we know
when you just increase artificial
liquidity try to paper over these
disasters
you're just delaying and exacerbating
the ultimate correction to economic
reality
and i think there was one headline um
i think it was jim cramer's show where
it showed like
bottom of the screen stock market
all-time high screen behind him
40 million americans unemployed so we've
the central
bank model has totally diverged
the market from its underlying valuation
fundamentals and now
everything's become much more a product
of policy
than supply and demand and
you know things would be pretty bleak
and grim without bitcoin right now
because it's the only thing that
um i guess is still rooted in supply and
demand
almost that you can find in the world
everything that can't be printed right
now is overpriced
right in commercial real estate equities
uh anything that's being substituted in
as a store value
since the store value function of money
has been totally compromised
fiat is at a historic
all-time high price point
and bitcoin it seems at least
that it's although it's at an all-time
high
it's really just beginning this long run
to actually
do what we say it was going to do which
is consume
all the monetary premium in the world
and you know
what we're trillion dollar asset today
that
store value market cap globally is
probably closer to 250 trillion
so hard to believe as it may be there's
still a lot of upside
in this market absolutely one of the
people who
unlike ray dalio uh really really
understands bitcoin and has become a
massive proponent since last time we
talked
is michael saylor you recently produced
an entire series
called the sailor series where you just
talked with him and so maybe talk
through a little bit uh
in terms of your understanding of his
worldview
and then what you took away from the
recording of that series
yeah so another
one of these just out of the blue events
was
actually sailor and microstrategy um
you know he was in a unique position and
that his company was sitting on a lot of
cash
um stealer for the audience may not know
is
the ceo of microstrategy they're a
nasdaq listed business intelligence firm
um they had been running a pretty
conservative ship
uh financially at least for the past
decade they're
sitting on a nice treasure of cash about
500 million dollars
and in the wake of kobet uh you know as
michael's making his media rounds he
just had to figure out what to do with
this melting ice cube
and they evaluated all their
alternatives and ultimately decided on
bitcoin
so it was interesting i think this was
august maybe when he announced
originally and i just woke up one day
saw this announcement i'm like what is
this it's crazy some big
corporation has bought a ton of bitcoin
and then in my i've got a twitter dm
from him and he's
sending me a link to the article and so
we start having a conversation
and you know it turns out he had been
following a lot of the the maximalists
and you know your show
and other people's writings for a long
time or you know relatively long time a
few months
and he the interesting interesting thing
about that for me was that this guy went
from essentially
you know he had disclaimed bitcoin back
in 2013 i don't think he thought a lot
about it between
13 and 2020 to my knowledge
then all of a sudden he has his covet
event where he has to reevaluate his
liquidity profile and how he's going to
maintain shareholder value um in the
treasury
so from march 2020 to august i was
talking about the course of five months
he basically
fully accelerated on the bitcoin rabbit
hole right he went through
all the all the content we produced all
the writing he knew it all
um and so the amazing thing about that
to me was
and i i thought this before that the
thesis of bitcoin although it's
extremely complicated
very multidisciplinary you have to
understand
things from many different angles to
really to grok bitcoin or to understand
it
the general value proposition is not
that complicated once you get it right
it's just
money that has a fixed supply
so you can't it's money that can't be
stolen value that can't be stolen to
inflation
deauthorization confiscation all of
these things
and i had this thesis that people would
wake up to this
relatively simple once this idea got out
and it
sort of shook off the flood that that
still plagues it a little bit
that people would um take this idea up
very quickly
because it's just money that can't be
reproduced in a world where money is
being
infinitely reproduced by the central
bank
and i thought he you know sailor's
acceleration in the rabbit hole was one
great example of that
he just he went zero to heroes so to
speak in this
course of a few months so in our
conversations
i was talking to him and i said you know
i had this idea for
a show i didn't even know what it would
be at this point podcast youtube channel
whatever i just said i wanted to sit
down
with the best thinkers in the bitcoin
space but also in
in the macroeconomic world so it's not
just a bitcoin focused
podcast and talk to them
[Music]
in a long form discussion so i would sit
down and talk to you as long as it took
we could talk for 50 hours if you wanted
and the idea was to get to the first
principles of your world view so
basically externalizing the mind
of these amazing thinkers and show the
world how they think how they build
their worldview
and my thesis behind this was that
in a lot of this coming from the book
sovereign individual which we talked
about last time too
in the 1500s i guess it was around 1490
when gutenberg invented the printing
press
we collapsed the cost of information
access
so all of a sudden we went from like 10
million books produced
in the prior 500 years there were 10
million books produced in a decade
once the printing press was made
available and the consequence of this
was
a there was a great many
more thinkers emerging in the world a
great uh
much more variety of thought emerging in
the world
and a lot of this uh new critical
thinking
was actually heretical to the
institution of the day which was the
church so the printing press sort of led
to the downfall of the church
as the dominant institution of the world
but the thought there was that it's the
when we decrease the cost of accessing
information
we actually increase general critical
thinking or general intelligence right
people can access information more
freely
ideas are much more free-flowing so
i thought that here in the digital age
maybe we're seeing something similar
we've once again collapsed the cost of
information
you know we have the the library of the
world so to speak at our fingertips
through a smartphone or a laptop
that maybe this would be a similar type
of vent
to the gutenberg printing press and
we're actually going to increase
critical flight thinking in the world
and increase kind of general
intelligence so
what i wanted to bring into this new
paradigm was
long-form discussions that would it
would almost be like the intellectual
olympics in a way
like you sit down and you see someone
that's got you know a long track record
of experience
um you know clearly a brilliant guy he
wrote a book in 2010 called the mobile
wave that basically said
go out and buy facebook apple amazon
netflix google they're going to dominate
the world
clearly that thesis played out perfectly
over the past decade
um and just
you know help spread i guess the
information
that these people have obtained uh that
they
that they've won basically through hard
one to experience
um throughout their careers and and
share that with the world and see if
people
um would have an affinity for it and it
turns out
i think the thesis is right so far i'm
getting feedback on the sailor series
specifically that
it's some of the best content people
have ever seen because this guy
gave you a little idea we really tried
to build
his entire worldview from first
principles so we started
in the stone age we're talking about
stone age technologies
like fire hydraulics which are you know
using water to overcome gravity
missiles and building
this view of how mankind
is the animal that channels energy
across time and space
toward the achievement of aims that's
what distinguishes us from every other
animal
is that we can plan we can build these
intellectual structures we then go out
and harness energy
to to energize those structures and
create things in the world that's what
civilization is
and just brick by brick building this
intellectual edifice that took us from
the stone age into the industrial age
into the digital age frankly and then uh
evaluating bitcoin to that long scope
of how this impacts everything going
forward how it totally changes the game
and sailor is just a master
speaker um he drops in so many
wonderful analogies comparing bitcoin to
the discovery of steel
or bitcoin to the discovery of
antiseptics right
um making the point that you know fiat
currency is like toxic money actually it
infects
our socioeconomic structures and now we
have a money that
that's basically free of
unpredictability
and how that's just a total game changer
so we recorded
um two sessions initially about five
hours each
that came out to about nine episodes
we're scheduled to do at least one more
session that could be between another
one and three episodes
uh going forward i'm going to sit down
with other prolific thinkers in the
space
jeff booth is next uh we're already
working on that conversation framework
uh just got an all-star cast lined up
and
for me this is amazing because this is
something i would be doing no matter
what
uh it really is a passion project it
deeply satisfies my own intellectual
curiosity as i'm trying to write and
think about these things
in new and varied perspectives like to
get inside someone's mind to this extent
changes me like i'm i now think
differently
as a result of interacting with sailor
uh throughout the series
and um yeah i'm just super excited about
it i think
um we can keep you know
i think people really like the first one
and i'm hoping they're gonna like
uh the ones to come here so absolutely
so michael saylor kind of cracked open
the dam
if you will in terms of uh corporations
buying bitcoin
uh and putting it on their balance sheet
uh he did it in a very kind of
transparent
uh honest way uh and what i mean by that
is uh he basically said to shareholders
i am considering doing this if you do
not want to be a part of this strategy
basically i'll buy back your shares at a
premium and then he went ahead and
started to execute this strategy
he has continued to kind of take out
very low interest
loans um or debt and
by using capital markets uh is able to
continue to fund the further
purchase of more and more bitcoin i
think he's at now over 90 000 bitcoin
that is put on that balance sheet kind
of four four and a half billion dollars
worth of value based on today's prices
talk a little bit about what you
evaluate
uh the impact of this decision obviously
we've seen square go out they did a 50
million dollar purchase that another 170
million
uh comes out to about five percent of
their cash position uh we've seen tesla
about seven eight percent of their cash
position about 1.5 billion
uh and there's a whole host of other
kind of you know crypto related
businesses that obviously hold bitcoin
on their
treasury as well in the public markets
but how do you evaluate
kind of what we're seeing with
corporations actually buying bitcoin and
putting it on their balance sheets
yeah i think at a very high level
we're seeing this game theory that many
bitcoiners have long identified you know
as early as 2011 12 13 14. we
knew how the game theory of money
operated
uh what was different about bitcoin is
that
this is the first asset that kind of
emerged at the retail level first
before permeating these larger levels of
uh organization
so i think that
it's a really really big deal i mean
sailor is will probably go down
i joked with him at the opening the show
that for a company called microstrategy
this might be the most brilliant macro
strategy ever executed
um if the bitcoin thesis continues to
play out
and the way that we think it will and
the way that it currently is
um you know he stands to become one of
the most
wealthy people in the world um and
microstrategy stands become one of the
most successful companies in the world
and it's it's all a result of
the game theory or the or you can also
think of this as
the vortex of incentives that is bitcoin
and that it basically has bootstrapped
itself into existence
by paying everyone to interact with it
and again we saw this work at the
individual level initially
where people could just mine it
convert electricity into bitcoin then
people found some value in its exchange
properties you know it can't be seized
it can be moved 24x7
etc etc so then it gained a market value
and as as has been said that was kind of
the
the miracle event once bitcoin
established a market exchange value
against fiat currency um it became that
was the beginning of its monetization
essentially
everything from that event has just been
a step function
of its uh constricting supply flow
so every four years is construct
constricting by 50 and it's just
bootstrapped itself upward and
for sailor to make a move that bold
i mean first of all this guy
was is predisposed to understanding
bitcoin
again a guy that wrote the mobile wave
he understands network effects he runs a
business intelligence firm he gets
software
i think the last piece that he dropped
in
after march 2020 was just you know
central banking basically or monetary
policy or austrian economics whatever
that monetary element was that he
plugged in just sort of crystallized
this world view for him on bitcoin
and no matter what amount of work
we have done like us bitcoin ambassadors
and
talking about and educating writing
about it uh
money always speaks louder than words
you know actions speak louder than words
so
the fact that he's now up to you know
the initial allocation was
500 million dollars from his treasury he
has since
taken on uh some very
cost effective debt i think his first
round of
convertible notes um unsecured debt was
it 75 basis points i think the latest
round was at
zero so it's literally taking on free
debt capital
um and the reason he's able to do that
is because of the optionality
bitcoin is installed on his balance
sheet effectively
so credit providers are willing uh
to lend him money at zero percent or 75
basis points
so that they can get the option on
uh microstrategy stock which has the
bitcoin on its balance sheet so it sort
of serves as a proxy for an option on
bitcoin effectively
and this all points to
kind of a point he's made repeatedly is
that every company now faces similar
incentives
they have to uh decide to plug
into the bitcoin network in one way or
another either putting it on their
balance sheet or as square is doing
they're selling bitcoin right which
forced other corporations
to adopt a similar strategy they have to
compete or die exactly so now paypal
selling bitcoin
um yeah i expect to see that continue
and um this
points to where i think fiat will just
ultimately fail against bitcoin because
everyone so now we've seen this game
theory permeate from the retail level
to corporates we now expect it in the
next
say five to ten years to see it permeate
at the sovereign wealth fund of the
central bank level
but every market actor whether you're an
individual or you're
at the other end of the spectrum faces
incentives today
to borrow dollars or borrow fiat
at low cost to buy bitcoin
on term debt and then pay back
depreciated dollars
so this is and this is something pierre
richard wrote about in 2014 it's called
speculative attack
right when every market actor faces
incentives
to borrow in the weak currency buy the
strong
money i don't like calling bitcoin to
currency because it's not governmental
so buy the strong money
sell the weak money buy the strong money
and then pay back the weak money at uh
after inflation has eroded some of that
real debt burden
this is like the uh
the the digital acid or something that's
going to be eating
the fiat structure from all sides and
that everyone wants to know
borrow and sell basically go short
dollars and long bitcoin
and this incentive is faced by all
market actors
um really starts to
make you believe that this thing could
all play out much more quickly
than we thought um you know even this
time last year
we were talking about this as like you
know ray dalio
had not taken any had not taken bitcoin
seriously at all up until that point
so in my mind then it was like oh we're
probably 25 years out
from a central bank taking this
seriously
but now you know coven as this great
accelerator has just changed everything
and uh it seems now that
um the the musical chairs the game of
musical chairs has started at the
corporate level
people are going to be racing to take a
seat at the table that is
the bitcoin network and now that we're
north
of a trillion dollar market cap uh we're
almost to the point where it's taken
very seriously as a macro asset
i'd say once you break five trillion
market cap uh it is a very serious
macro asset and then every capital pool
the world will want to have uh
some exposure to it that's when things
get really interesting
because the
supply curve of bitcoin like it's it's
perfect information
we all know what it is now all the way
into the future
and thus far in its history its price
has adhered to that supply curve
so we're still what we're seeing today
is still a function of
the may 2020 having right we typically
have these having events
12 to 18 months later we have a huge
price pump
if that pattern continues to repeat the
incentives to front run bitcoin become
astronomical
because everyone's looking at the same
curve saying this thing's just going to
keep going up
i my strategy is to sit down at this
table before anyone else sits down on
this table
as the as market actors do that they're
actually increasing the market cap of
bitcoin
increasing the likelihood of its success
and further imposing that calculus on
other
market actors so i think it is just a
very
interesting event i think sailor will be
regarded
as a pioneer frankly in bitcoin
um and he you know
he is proving that thesis at the
corporate level and now i think
we're just waiting with baited breath to
see it happen
at the central bank level yeah so
speaking of that
i think that everyone knew individuals
were buying i think that
there had been a lot of focus on
financial institutions kind of wall
street
showing up i actually think we have
really bad
short-term memories not that many people
were ready for corporations in 2020 and
into 2021
but that has happened in a much faster
clip than i thought
you know uh was previously expected
anyone who would
have claimed in beginning of 2020 that
within a year
uh tesla would be buying a billion and a
half dollars of bitcoin on their balance
sheet
uh i think would uh would be absolutely
nuts
and i think from there what you end up
getting is
uh the final question which is what
about the central banks
right so we have individuals we have
financial institutions we have
corporations
that next big inflection point is a
central bank where many central banks
doing this i think your opinion is that
it is inevitable
but is that actually inevitable why do
you think that
and kind of what is the timeline that
you think is most reasonable when
evaluating
yeah tesla is a great example of
just the second step in that game of
musical chairs right
sailor buys 1.3 billion at the time i
think
that was 1.3 tesla buys 1.5 right so i
would exp
i think those numbers um
are closely related for a reason right
saying like how much should we buy
and tesla's treasurer or cfo saying well
how much did the other guy buy about 1.3
let's buy 1.5
so that as silly as it sounds i think
that's actually how a lot of this game
will be played out
in terms of the timing of central bank
purchase it is so
impossible to say and i know it's kind
of a cop-out but
the digital age if it has proven
anything to us
it is that the exponential
change it is brought about is
so holistically unfathomable how fast it
can be
um you know we've gone from in the past
20 years
from the internet say 25 years the
internet
is a joke to everything's on the
internet
now everything right everything we do
and not only that the internet also
is in our pocket now or the fully baked
internet
we're not talking about the little nokia
flip phone with a
mediocre browser it's it's a super
computer now in our pocket
and it's only getting faster
so the i really
am increasingly of the belief that we
are in
a renaissance-like event the world will
look back on this
uh this period in history as
a major mega-political transition
from an analog age into a digital age
right in the same way we look back
at the transition from the agricultural
age to the industrial age for instance
and all of the institutions
that served us in the past right if we
if we think just looking at the central
bank itself
the structure of the central bank is
characterized by the money
right so the money is upstream of
everything the reason we have a central
bank
frankly is because gold is expensive
to secure and it's heavy and it's hard
to move across
space so we had a great
tool that was selected on the
marketplace for holding its value across
time uh which was gold well it became
kind of
globally dominant money but it
constricted our ability
to scale economic activity because it's
hard
it's very expensive to transact across
space and for a global
a world becoming characterized by
globalized trade
if you imagine that we had to actually
ship gold around the world for every
transaction
uh it kind of points towards how
self-defeating and
how expensive that would be so we the
central bank
emerged as the ultimate custodian of
gold
and it issued paper currency
to augment the lack of portability in
gold
so now we have this large custodian
that centrally manages the gold and
issues paper backed by it
but with this
custody model came the requirement to
trust the central bank
that they won't abuse the money supply
right that they'll always maintain
a one-to-one pack between currency and
gold
and clearly that trust if nothing else
defines the history of banking is that
that trust is violated repeatedly
um so in a way it's as if
gold is the game we've always been
playing
um you know we could say that another
way to think about this is that
it's the common misconception today is
that
governments are the originators of money
governments issue money
but that's not actually true what
money emerges when we have property
rights basically
so when we uh in the agricultural age
and we started creating
savings in the form of grain capital
etc to protect that capital
the protection service was the
government so it's the local group that
specialized in violence that protected
you from other specialists and violence
to protect those savings so money
government actually emerges from money
basically once we have property and
savings the government emerges as a
protection service for those savings
the
the type of money we have again has
shaped the institutions we have today so
we've got
gold leading to the central bank and
the question now becomes we've been
playing this one game everyone's trying
to accumulate as much money as possible
across history
that led to gold becoming the most
dominant money in the world
the question now becomes
5 000 year old tech gold 12 year old
tech
bitcoin a digital disrupter to the only
game we've ever been playing
the original governor of human action if
you will
money is the governor of human action
not government it's whoever holds the
gold makes the rules
as the old accident goes
this i think bitcoin makes it so
interesting
is that it is the latest and greatest
testament
to the disruptive potential of the
digital age
we've already seen digital age totally
upend
say the uh the media landscape the
advertising landscape
um taxis ride sharing like you name the
industry
it's been impacted more or less severely
by digital
technology but at the the pinnacle
of this this sub this uh recurrent
analog institution disruption the
largest and most dominant world
is the central bank which is premised on
gold
and now we have this digital tool
disrupting it from the bottom up right
it's disrupting gold which then opens
the central bank model
makes it irrelevant and
that you know the the 100 trillion
dollar question so to speak is what are
they going to do about it
what are they going to do it's
increasingly obvious that most attack
vectors on bitcoin
just will not work to stop it outright
there's
in all of the thinking that's been done
about bitcoin no one has identified
a credible unilateral attack vector
that could take down the network i mean
the the analogous question is
how do you shut down the internet
worldwide
forever it's not even good enough to
shut it down for just a day you need to
shut it down permanently
everywhere um so short of like a
super global catastrophe
there's not a lot that can be done to
stop the internet therefore there's not
a lot that can be done to stop bitcoin
so then the question becomes what are
they going to do to adapt to this new
reality
and as i've argued in a lot of my
writing
uh this is kind of like the old i think
it was gandhi that maybe said this
who knows i read it on the internet so
it might be wrong first they
laugh at you then they fight you then
they
uh adopt to whatever
first first they ignore you then they
laugh at you then they fight you then
you win
that's right exactly so bitcoin's going
through that progression
essentially and i think we may be
somewhere at the fight stage maybe
kind of coming out of bitcoin's
honeymoon period maybe they do
uh attempt to increase regulatory
hostility towards bitcoin
at the end points you know exchanges and
custodians and other venues
uh which is points to the importance of
always holding your own keys
um but i think bitcoin
survives that because again the network
will survive that there's
none government doesn't have any
mechanisms
that can really jeopardize the network
itself they can sort of just impact the
consumer endpoints
so when we get beyond the fight stage
that's when i think they just start
acquiring it as a means of
of insurance against its success
you already hear rumors about you know
venezuela doing this
they're selling passports for bitcoin
you hear rumors about countries in the
middle east
actually monetizing um some of their
their energy there
with bitcoin mining uh also using it as
a means to circumvent u.s sanctions
so there are all of these sources of
demand for bitcoin
that no government can eradicate and
i think the first central bank that
publicly discloses the purchase of
bitcoin is just going to heat this thing
up to a level of
of game theory that we can't even
imagine um because then
you're running the same calculus but at
a level
where not only do they have the largest
balance sheets in the world
but they can also just print money and
buy the thing
so that's when i expect escape velocity
for bitcoin to be achieved so if we zoom
out for a second
um and we basically look at this as
um it's pretty un well understood how we
got here at this point right if you've
been paying attention if you've been
um kind of interested or cured or
curious
you can go read that everywhere i think
what people are trying to figure out is
where are we going
um and so if we look forward i don't
know
25 years what does that world look like
is bitcoin in every individual every
financial institution
every corporation's balance sheet and
every central bank reserve
are there uh all-out violent wars over
this
just walk me through from where we are
today
to what you think you know 25 years from
now the world looks like and then
how do we get there
yeah this is uh extremely
complicated question because we quite
actually have no
historical precedent whatsoever
another way to maybe think about this
is the way
the models of socioeconomic organization
we have right whether it's capitalism or
socialism
um they're they're really just
social devices or or you could think of
them like a
tool basically itself so in the 20th
century for instance
we had this both ideological and
economic
contention between soviet russia which
was
a command and control economy and u.s
capitalism and the reason
us out-competed the ussr and the ussr
ultimately broke down
bankrupted and fragmented is because the
model of we'll see capitalism in
parentheses because it's not pure
capitalism they've always had
essentially planned money but
it was most markets were free compared
to soviet russia where
no markets were free it's because they
were able to mobilize
the collective intelligence of market
actors
through the price signal and therefore
they're able to
uh create a lot more wealth through
trade so it's a
more energy efficient right we gain more
energy efficiency or productivity by
trading with one another
then we do having one singular plan or
director
tell us what to do because the
intelligence of that
bureaucratic body can never rival the
intelligence of
a distributed network of market actors
so you had this distributed distributed
computing network
a free market capitalist competing
against a centralized computing network
of soviet russia pricing czar right
us capitalism therefore outcompeted
soviet communism for that reason it was
a more energy-efficient tool
if you will and i think that
whatever this model that comes in the
wake of bitcoin we could say
it's purified capitalism like in the
original sense of capitalism which has
minimized state intervention
um i in some of my more recent writing
have started to call it
sovereignism because for the first time
in history bitcoin it
gives individuals and entities any
market actor
full sovereignty over their own money
they don't need to depend on
any other custodian or institution to
facilitate value flows across space and
time
so it enables this new mode of
of socioeconomic organization that's
that was never before possible
for bitcoin and that's why i think it is
difficult to comprehend the implications
of this
um and difficult to explain frankly
because we don't have a lot of
direct historical analogy but to get a
sense
of and
where this goes and why i think it goes
that direction
we can just look at the average u.s
taxpayer
so the average u.s taxpayer today is
paying about
ten thousand dollars ten thousand five
hundred dollars each year
to the irs so direct taxation
that's the average tax bill um
that does not include inflation so that
does not include loss of purchasing
power on inflation
which as we've touched on before uh the
quote that everyone loved is there's no
better way
to fertilize the rich man's field uh
than with the sweat of the poor man's
brow that's what inflation is
essentially it disproportionately
affects
the poor retirees pensioners anyone
living on fixed income so it's an
additional
invisible tax but we won't even look at
that we'll just look at direct taxation
ten thousand dollar ten thousand five
hundred dollars per year paid in direct
taxes to the irs
if that amount of money the ten thousand
dollars was instead
put into a savings account that yielded
ten percent per year
over 40 years so after 40 payments
uh and 40 years of interest accrual to
that account
that sum becomes 4.4 million dollars
so the incentive that just the average
u.s taxpayer faces the guy paying
stroking a check 10 000 per year to the
irs
the decision of whether or not to adopt
bitcoin becomes
would you switch your savings account
from your local bank
to the bank of bitcoin for 4.4 million
dollars in retirement savings
and again we haven't even included
inflation which if we look at inflation
in 2020 uh u.s tax revenue direct tax
credit was 3.9 trillion dollars
we printed about 4.1 trillion dollars
so we could say that the inflation tax
was you know
effectively doubled the direct tax rate
so you could say that ten thousand
dollar uh payment per year
probably getting hit for another ten
thousand dollars per year
uh based on inflation now again it
depends where he's at in the in the
hierarchy he does the old assets so the
old dollars et cetera et cetera
um but we could say that okay that 4.4
million would then be an 8.8 million
dollar
decision for your average guy your
average guy or girl
this although i don't think clearly not
many market actors have awakened
to this calculus yet i think over time
as governments are increasingly bankrupt
right we know that
governments are the least efficient
operators in the world
just go to your local dmv to see how
efficient things are
they they're not accountable to their p
l like every other entrepreneur in the
world they're just able to print money
and paper over mistakes and bad decision
making and continue
uh and the example of this that i think
safety
pointed out was in lebanon they have the
the lebanese rail authority railroad
authority
still operates today and they haven't
had a track a railroad in lebanon for
like 30 years
so it's like these these i forget who
said
there's nothing more permanent than a
temporary government solution
so they're eight the only reason they're
able to do that is because they're able
to steal
from society so governments need to
steal
more and more over time to remain
relevant
as that overreach escalates market
actors are going to wake up
to this option this exit option like i
can just go into bitcoin
and get out of the inflation game or or
whatever tax they're being hit with
they can go and hold bitcoin uh borrow
against it even right which is a tax
efficient strategy of taking liquidity
against it
and and suffer no no tax impact i think
this creates
a hydraulic pressure pushing market
actors
to the exit right will be to exit the
fiat currency complex and go into
bitcoin
and every incremental
saver that decides to hold their savings
in bitcoin
necessarily has to divest their fiat so
they're selling fiat to buy bitcoin
right
and this further accelerates uh the
inflationary pressures on the dollar
which further accelerates other market
actors exiting so this is the feedback
loop that i think
drives people into bitcoin people and
market actors
institutions and everything over time so
then the question becomes
which is very deeply and interestingly
explored in the book the sovereign
individual
what happens next because if everyone
moves their savings into bitcoin all of
a sudden
inflation is no longer a revenue source
for the government which again if we
look at the us government last year that
was 50
of their revenue pretty much was
inflation direct
taxation becomes much more complicated
because
all of a sudden you're in this asset
that is largely unrealized gains
for people that are holding savings in
it you can't really tax unrealized gains
like you pass the law on it but you're
just
then encouraging people to take their
savings elsewhere
which with bitcoin you have this hyper
mobile capital you can move to any
jurisdiction in the world
anyone that treats you well right you
can go and take the residence there
so it's this escalation
um i guess this option for people to
move their savings into a non-state
bank which we call bitcoin like the
ultimate offshore bank if you will
it's going to force governments to treat
their citizens more honestly
it's going to force them to compete for
citizenship
to compete for their business so to
speak so it's imposing
uh the free market paradigm on at the
governmental
level which is not something they're
accustomed to they're accustomed to
treating their taxpayers
like cattle right they could just raise
them up sheer them down whenever they
need to
um which is the analogy that the book
uses actually says
in the 21st century those cows will grow
wings basically
and we can now take flight and and uh go
and move to where we are treated best
so as inflation revenues go to zero
or near zero taxation revenues start to
collapse as well
this bankrupts the nation-state model of
human organization
and so the big question is what happens
now
how do we organize ourselves
post-statism
and i've started writing a series on
this i
you know it's difficult to
explain and comprehend what happens uh
we have a few analogies like i alluded
to the one about soviet russia
earlier um the book goes into some more
examples about what happened
post-feudalism how society restructured
itself
um but it's important to realize
that it's the old andreessen
quote right the software is eating the
world that just rings
louder and louder to me with every
passing year so
it's not just every business is in the
technology game now like you can't
you can't not be in the technology game
like everyone uses technology it's just
it's very deeply enmeshed in our
day-to-day life as we're proving right
now
on this call it's also eating
the institutions we have used to
organize ourselves across history for
hundreds of years like the dominant
institution of the world
now faces digital disruption
by bitcoin and um
i don't know i would say for deeper
thoughts on that come check out the
series
i'm writing it covers the sovereign
individual but also
uh putting some of my my own lens
on it and also things i've learned in
these these conversations like with
sailor and others about how they
see the future playing out when you
think back to
what does happen when that kind of
status uh
environment fails or or at least
drastically reduces in its power
and kind of reach um
soviet russia i think you mentioned
feudalism
what happened in those situations or
what are the main takeaways that people
should know about yeah the first thing
that tends to happen is um governments
get increasingly desperate
right they're basically so you can think
of inflation by the way as a slow
implicit default of government
they have they have cash are they
written checks that they can't cash
effectively so they're defaulting on
this debt in slow motion by inflating
the currency so they'll print more
currency to pay their bills
and they they externalize the cost of
that money printing onto society
so by printing money or engaging in
quantitative easing
the central bank is harvesting the
economic surplus
of the of entrepreneurs of the
productive economy
they're not infusing any new wealth into
the economy printing
like creating a new paper certificate
that we call the dollar
that is not value that is just a claim
on the savings that we've created in the
world the buildings the equipment the
time
the knowledge all of that uh
late stage governments tend to be
printing faster and faster
because this thing as we we've touched
on previously
the fiat currency complex being a debt
based money
it requires steadily more collateral
and leverage to remain sustainable right
there's this uh increasing appetite
for interest basically to be siphoned
off the productive economy and back to
the owners
uh of the debt and this thing
and all of the costs of that are
externalized through inflation so it
tends to accelerate
uh when we look at something like weimar
germany
this has really perverse consequences
actually because people
think they're getting wildly rich
they their homes are becoming more
valuable their businesses are increasing
in value so
all assets denominated in
the failing currency are becoming
nominally more expensive so it has this
deceptive quality of thinking
you're becoming wealthy when in fact
it's the currency that is failing um
so i would say that tends to be one
thing another thing that that happens
which i
would argue we're seeing today is that
since nothing holds value there's no
sound store value people become
uh their time preferences increase a lot
which means they become much more
uh likely to gamble and engage in super
risky ventures
um they you know gambling in the stock
market was a big thing in weimar germany
i would say that's what we're seeing
today in a lot of ways there's a lot of
um you know not not to knock on the wall
street
that's group i think they've done an
amazing thing by proving
uh a d the effectiveness of a
decentralized organization versus
centralized organizations
but there's a lot of gambling there too
right it's people are just getting easy
money borrowing easy money and they're
just betting on stock prices going up
forever
so um
increased speculation in in stock and
other other asset categories um
and then see the currency is getting
deprecated all the while and then
what finally happens is that people try
to get their money out of the country
right when the the writing is clearly on
the wall for everyone
um that this thing's going into
hyperinflation people either try to get
trade their money for consumable or
durable goods things that can't be
printed
things that have uh an energy intensity
or
require sacrifice to produce whether
this is food or buildings or anything
that
that's a real capital asset or they try
to get
their money actually out of the country
and transmit it to somewhat to a
jurisdiction with a more uh more stable
monetary regime and
the the endgame of that too
like we saw in with ussr is that
the whole this giant nation
was held together basically by its
ability to confiscate wealth from all
its
uh citizens when that mechanism breaks
down
uh the country tends to fragment so so
government shrinks things relocalize in
the case of the ussr
there are a lot of these countries that
end in stan that were formerly
conquered that became independent
countries again so the the overarching
theme is that
as the nation-state model is bankrupted
it tends to fragment um
into smaller pieces and um
you know ultimately relocalizes
government
when you think through um what would
happen in the united states
is it a replica of uh those situations
that you just described
or do you think that the creation
and uh kind of pervasiveness of
technology
uh would actually change maybe what
happens in the analog
uh geography-based world and actually
there would be more of a fragmentation
a coalescing uh in kind of a digital
world like how do you look at
soviet russia uh it's really hard to
kind of understand what would have
happened if there was the internet and
kind of when all that played out but any
thoughts there of comparing
the uh uh the digital world and um
and kind of the analog world yeah i
think the
big difference here
is that again market actors in those
situations would try to leave
one bad situation to get into a less bad
situation so to get out of
uh maybe the russian rule and into the
u.s dollar for instance
um there was no true
exit option there was no way out of fiat
currency because all or we could say
monopolized currencies they haven't
always been fiat but they've always been
centrally controlled and planned
you could only move from one centrally
planned monetary regime to another
it's kind of your best hope but bitcoin
is
it's a radically new frontier because it
is this
unstoppable free market money right
you think of it think of it as a
global digital non-state based money
for a for a non-state economy right that
we can actually
enter this digital domain that no
nation state has dominion over
um and actually the individual is is
empowered maximally
to with options basically you have
optionality and optionality is freedom
that you can now move your capital
anywhere in the world you can custody it
in any number of high security schemas
and whatnot
so how this plays out
in say maybe the united states is i
think you could see a similar
fragmentation
uh i believe actually in the texas state
constitution
they have the right to succeed from the
united states
based on a number of parameters and
someone can fact-checking on that
it's been a few years since i've looked
at it but
when centralized power structures
are getting you know defunded so to
speak as savers are moving into bitcoin
they lose relevance in many ways and so
i think you would see
especially powers that are uh we could
say
say governments that are self-sufficient
like a texas has its own energy grid
it's got coastal access it's you know
relatively large geography
you'd see something like that maybe take
place first maybe texas could actually
uh break off in the u.s but
in the long run people just start to
self-organize
it it moves away from this top-down
monopolistic command-and-control economy
where you're told what to do
right you just how many of us have
consensually negotiated
our tax treaties with the government
right we don't
we get a bill that says this is what you
pay these are the services you get
you're welcome right you don't get any
say-so in that that commercial
interaction
but or we will or we will send armed men
to put you in jail exactly right
um and sailor had a great analogy for
this too he's saying that
everyone in miami is very polite
because most people carry firearms
right so even a sweet old lady like
you're going to be extra polite to
everyone because you never know who's
packing heat so this
the the option to do a thing can be more
powerful than actually doing the thing
it doesn't mean people are running
around miami shooting each other
necessarily but just the fact that they
possibly could
tends to make people uh accord uh a
little more nicely than they might
otherwise
so bitcoin restores this symmetry of
power between the individual and
government or institutions
um in a way that we've never seen before
it really is something radically new um
and yeah i think that
we'll we already see so much
self-organization in the digital age
right we the groups like uh these
clubhouse chats
i don't know if you've been involved a
few of those recently like these are
people just coalescing around an idea
talking about it forming their own
independent networks
removing information and capital now
through these apps
and electronic media through digital
media it's like
in the property rights basically which
by the way that's what government's
original
intent was right it was to preserve the
peace in the local environment protect
the property so people could trade
and people could resolve any uh disputes
about private property
non-violently they could have recourse
to the courts so they didn't have to go
and you know raise pitchforks against
one another well now property rights
in bitcoin are preserved by the mining
network
right it's it's disrupted the need the
original need for government so
government
just like gold is being disrupted from
its original principles of money
like the five properties it's bitcoin's
more divisible durable recognizable
portable scarce and gold that's why it's
out competing it
bitcoin better secures property rights
again in a
if we look at a tool or socioeconomic
structure as being
the the system or idea that best
allocates energy
across time so how do we spend the least
energy possible towards satisfying this
aim
the aim of property rights just being
that whatever
fruits of my labor that i sacrifice to
obtain something i can preserve that
in something so if it's a physical item
i actually need a little bubble of uh
protection around me otherwise people
can just come and steal your stuff and
you don't have police to call
you don't have courts etc etc but with
bitcoin we have this property right
that's you know it's metaphysical it's
just digital information
uh must much more cost effective to
secure
and it exists independent of the courts
of the monopoly on violence of
government entirely
so now that people are able to do this
people are empowered
with all with all of this optionality to
communicate and move capital
uh across these self-organizing digital
networks it just obfuscates the need
for nation-state organization and
private property protection so
you know my my high level thesis on all
of this
because again it's hard to get it all
into words is that the world is becoming
a video game
basically is it all more and more of our
relationships and important functions in
life
are mediated by digital technology and
screens
um you know dating is a video game now
people are swiping left swiping right
all of these important things that we
used to need to do
many of the important things we used to
have to do in person we can now do
digitally and
that just decreases the need for the
analog institutions that that provided
security
pre-digital in the digital age so
and who knows like you know the tech is
just getting started by the way
like we're still hamstrung i think in
many ways that we need a laptop or we
need a smartphone what happens when
augmented reality or virtual reality
really becomes more mainstream
and they were able to overlay the real
world with digital data
either you know the whole idea of google
glass was to get the tech out of the way
so the more the hardware gets out of the
way i think the more we accelerate
this transition into sovereignism
or or post-state capitalism whatever you
want to call it
yeah it's fascinating to me to kind of
think through this because i think you
you said it perfectly nobody actually
knows
right um before uh before we wrap up
is there anything specific uh that you
can identify that
uh other than central bank starting to
buy bitcoin
that you would say is hey this is an
inflection point or a milestone
that i've got my eye on i don't know
when it happens but when it happens
people will be able to say
that is you know an important moment
um
yeah definitely you know touched on the
central bank
buying it i think i'll say this about
the pandemic situation um
actually the book sovereign individual
has been pressured in a lot of ways
and a pandemic was actually
predicted in that book to be used as one
of the main state responses to social
upheaval
and immediately before the pandemic we
had
unprecedented millions worldwide
protesting their government there's
still a lot of it going on today
um so i don't i don't know you know
that's the timing of that is
quite interesting to me either that
and i'm not saying necessarily that the
a lot of people call it the scam dimmick
like i don't know that it was purely
manufactured or created but
the state response to the virus
has certainly been many orders of
magnitude
uh more severe than prior health scares
you know we had the swine flu and all
these things before that
government didn't react in this way so
there seems to be
mixed motives let's say of this this
latest
uh response um
i think
you know another breakthrough will be
when we see
a lot of state like so there for
instance in north america um
a lot of the energy infrastructure
specifically on like related to natural
gas
is just wasted today so
that wasted that flared natural gas
could be capped with bitcoin mine and
monetize instead so bitcoin
as we've discussed previously it
provides this energy buyer of last
resort
i think states too will be really forced
to embrace bitcoin for that reason
because again they're suffering
financially as well they're trying to
print more money to stay ahead of
um stay ahead of their own bad decision
making historically
and i think that they kind of get forced
further along the risk
spectrum as well that they need to start
mining bitcoin and that states that
control
uh these energy sources or energy
producers
that would otherwise not
that otherwise would not have a way to
monetize that
energy will now be forced to start
monetizing i think that could become an
inflection point
for bitcoin that when you actually see
um
you know large territories monetizing uh
unused or underused energy sources into
bitcoin
um then it's only a step functional way
of those producers themselves
accepting payment in bitcoin holding
bitcoin
you've now reduced the selling pressure
on bitcoin again
because miners which today are
the source of most most of the uh open
market selling
to cover their energy bills and
operational expenditures
that source of selling goes away so now
you put even more upward pressure on the
price
um and you know another point that was
made recently was a lot of these miners
that are going public
they'll go into capital markets and
borrow at
bar against their balance sheet at 0 or
50 or maybe 100 basis points
and just pay their bills with with
leverage with debt capital
leverage level up and take uh pay that
bills with debt capital
such that they can hold more that
bitcoin on the balance sheet so i think
there's a lot of these avenues that are
going to really
constrict the selling of bitcoin by
miners
over time and i think those will be
major inflection points
um because i'll just put so much upward
pressure on the bitcoin price
that it will you know potentially push
us into this
hyper bitcoinization type scenario
i am uh i am on uh the same wavelength
as you are
as uh this is all gonna happen it's a
foregone conclusion
uh it's just a matter of how
aggressively
it happens uh and ultimately what that
timeline looks like
but as we have learned those who have
the kind of longest term
horizon uh tend to get the best rewards
uh in this game and so i think you've
done a fantastic job of articulating
that over uh over the years
and continuing to do so now um for
people who want to
uh go watch the sailor series uh or
watch some of the other series that
you've coming out where can we send them
to
uh to find you on the internet or find
those uh pieces of content that you're
putting out
yeah um and thanks for having me i think
you know you're doing a great job
with this platform you've definitely
pioneered a lot of the space yourself
and bringing more mass awareness to
bitcoin and
and this mass transformational
wave of innovation that we're we're
living through so thanks for that
um my twitter page is where i post
links to most of my work my last name is
breedlove
so my twitter handle is at read love22
b-r-e-d-l-o-v-e 2-2
the show is called the what is money
show
uh and i named it that by the way
because
as we know describing bitcoin in a few
words
especially for someone that doesn't
understand it is not very easy there's a
lot
to unpack there but i found that
this question what is money like if you
can get someone just asking themselves
that question
seriously and researching it uh
diligently that they'll stumble on kind
of the gold and bitcoin
thesis at some point so i'm trying to
kind of incept sort of like inception
that movie where you're just planning
this little seed
getting people to ask themselves the
question what is money and i think it
just
uh continues to uncover a lot of
interesting
truth for me as well it's just a it's a
really deep question seemingly simple
but actually really deep
um so you can that's on uh both youtube
so it's the what is money show you can
search by my name on youtube we also
have a website for it which is what is
moneypodcast.com
um we just again released the sailor
series we're almost done with that one
uh booth series will be next uh and then
i've got a big
big cast for the first 10 long form
series
um yeah that's it that's me
all right at breedlove22
on uh twitter right
yes awesome man listen robert i
i really really enjoy talking to you
every time we will definitely do this
again in the future so thanks so much
for doing it
and uh hopefully everyone learned
assumptions
i hope so thanks again for having me